[Music]
in crazy stalker news submitted by
Congrats Bart NGO Congrats to them
they're there at maternity and paternity
leave let relations 21-year woman
control their ex-boyfriends life for two
years by impersonating police officers
what did she do wall she's smart she's
[ __ ] crazy the guy's pretty but I
mean like how I think how do you do that
like she would get on the phone like she
would hang up officer Clancy he hangs up
the phone with another cop yeah what do
you say Dalton yeah so this girl her
name is Lauren 21 years old so she was
dating this dude named Mitchell 22 years
old a couple met through mutual friends
they had a sexual relationship
they were only dating for a couple
months and that's when Mitchell was like
you know I think we're good like let's
not see each other anymore
yeah buddy was not good at that time is
when she claimed to be the victim of a
sexual assault and she wanted Mitchell's
support and so he agreed to give a an
email statement to this certain police
officer named Robert hey and supposedly
this police officer was a family friend
and so that's when Lauren started
impersonating this police officer and
then so between December 2014 and
February of this year
Lauren persistently kept contacting
Mitchell using three different email
addresses belonging to fictional
officers and she also created two
Facebook accounts pretending to be her
own friends and used them to repeatedly
criticized him for engaging and
relationships with other girls
oh my god was it like guys do
that's right he said I'm like this guy's
what are you doing in this relationship
see so it was the whole clan see and
everything that's why I got a lot
through email oh she never spoke over
the phone
mmm but that's what his voice would have
sounded like really so then she made him
believe that he was subject to curfews
and he was also restricted from going to
certain places and also seeing other
women the cop said you can't see this
other girl or like she was saying but
apparently this cop by the name would
allow after Mitchell went out with this
one girl this one time around that the
beginning of this whole thing that's
when this officer emailed Mitchell
saying like hey why did you make Lauren
upset by going out with that woman well
that's what he found out that was the
beginning well what he questioned why
would a cop care about Lauren
exactly he's the emotional police what
the [ __ ] know the justification of him
caring about Lauren is because he was a
family friend that's what she painted
this do to be I can't believe that she
threatened no one like if you go to this
restaurant over here you're gonna go
jail yeah what what what what yeah and
then so hereís barred him from going to
certain places like certain bars and
restaurants dude I would look in Fridays
Saturdays and Sundays he couldn't go out
and so I pretty much ended its social
life why the cop said if you go out
those days I would arrest you
this was so [ __ ] dumb right you're so
I was like
[Laughter]
why are you farting such weird technique
where I'm trying to wave it away from
you guys this is the last one we'll get
through this
her jacket was a dark blue before you
start a party bro so yeah she would
continue to brand him with legal action
if he didn't comply with all of her
demand and so she would also have
threatened him with fines of three
thousand pounds for wasting police time
and fifteen thousand pounds if Lauren's
case did not succeed of her being like
the sexual assault victim and so he
abided by this the two years how did he
find out the way this all came out
finally was that he eventually went to
the police station two years yeah and
then that's when officers locative we're
like dude come on why would a police
officer give a [ __ ] about any of these I
would have been in tears like have now
been jail for nine months she's she
can't see the victim obviously is there
a picture of the guy oh my see what
stupid looks like oh my god wake up and
smell the coffee dude smell the coffee
huh look at nineties TV drama yeah he
dies like a Dookie but he also looks he
also looks really young he's in Dawson's
Creek I think she looks cute too I'm
like damn I would never thought you were
that crazy well you can't judge a book
by it's cover cheap oh there's a crazy
it's all right there in the eyes that's
crazy [ __ ] off the bridge man
manipulative or did it well you'd be
there what would you do to her on the
street like if you knew what you did
yeah we think about this she's walking
down a cobblestone alleyway like tea and
crumpets he's like she's walking
straight towards you and it's just you
and her what do you think what do you do
Jamal yeah that's true it is really fun
you're so I feel like this kid literally
went to the police station and he goes
excuse me I need to see the love police
you know the love police that he's with
relationships like manipulative women
like this like you like or dislike oh I
heard like you why why is that my friend
he had an ex-girlfriend like when he
broke up with her she's like I - help me
for you raped me women like that old you
need to be killed I don't give a [ __ ]
people do that yeah - that's [ __ ]
yeah how would he do that cuz she's a
[ __ ] yeah see there needs to be a prison
specifically for these types of people
they should be put to prison for at
least half the time that that man should
have been in prison I bet you this fool
has donated at least $30,000 to some
African dude
like in Craigslist some Nigerian prince
he is 22 you can't be dumb no you're not
that I was double 21 20 21 but 22 what
else when one feels gullible because I
want to help people so bad you know like
when someone's like oh no okay I'll help
you like you know I am I want to help
people and then it's [ __ ] me over
quite a few times and then now I'm you
never help me [ __ ] but cop tried to
threaten me over email it's no sorry
roof on the email you just have to ask
which department what is your badge
number what's your badge number
what is it and she would be like one two
three four five anybody okay cool think
so yeah man I got one email from my
coracle Apple but then the actor said
you one hacker way yeah females like Oh
something your Facebook is about to get
shut down because you know blog please
respond if I've got enough in the bank
yeah you're a Bank of America things
like messed up you need to log into this
and I just got this one from a [ __ ]
was they called the IRS CIO like
thousands of dollars so like I would
send them like you need to respond with
your login and email be like hey my
emails this and my password is I love
big [ __ ] 143 and I'm pretty sure they
typed it didn't try it too well he he oh
there's one guy who did that but he
didn't know how to CC so I was just like
30 people on the list like I said I'm
like if you're gonna [ __ ] scam people
please make sure not Oliver like all of
our emails on showing and he responded
with I screwed up sad face and it's like
an old man said wait it's not like two
dots and set it's like a two dots a nose
and a bracket like that's an old man
smiley 1999 through the nose yeah that
is so sad no I [ __ ] hate this [ __ ]
just Thoreau bridge she's useless to us
I didn't think she thought it was gonna
be that easy I think she just got
carried away with it but she's so
[ __ ] manipulative and insecure that
seeks effort right
that takes a lot of years what does she
do to like she did these emails so he'll
keep taking her on dates and stay with
her no they don't elaborate on that part
of the story to keep him isolated
I think the isolation it's like a social
experiment for her I think she was just
like what can I do to stop her and he
wasn't that good-looking either he's not
terrible he's not ugly I know I'm saying
was dicta fide when girls get dicta fied
they get they get very well just
biscuits yeah if it's that is this
driving weird that [ __ ] crazy or
maybe she just has problem taking
rejection yeah you know I reject you you
don't reject me I hope you guys enjoy
this video for more please subscribe to
our Channel and you can check out the
last video right here
[Music]